Lina: "I have merely been transplanted from one scene of student-life to another." That's a young man writing from Cambridge in 1859.
Maya: Transplanted. That's such a brave word for, "I already miss home."
Theo: And we have that sentence because the letter became a book, the book became a scan, and the scan became crawler food.
Maya: Crawler food?
Theo: That's the technical term. Pen to pixel in one hundred and fifty-four years.
Lina: And after all that survival, what survives emotionally is so simple: he knows home is about to become somewhere he visits.
Maya: the idea of going away for good and all, and always hereafter being at home only as a visitor.
Theo: That phrase gets worse the longer you sit with it.
Maya: Welcome to The Homes We Leave Behind. I'm Maya.
Theo: I'm Theo.
Lina: And I'm Lina.
Theo: Quick note on where all this comes from: every source today was grabbed by a web crawler in December 2013.
Lina: That's when it was captured, not necessarily when it was written. That 1859 letter?
Maya: It was sitting on the Internet Archive as a raw text file—an OCR dump of a scanned book, complete with broken line breaks and a stray page number header.
Lina: So December is the shelf date, not the birth date.
Maya: Today we're asking what happens when the place you call home becomes a place you can only visit.
Theo: And that ache turned up everywhere in this archive—old letters, blog posts, a grief journal on a health website.
Lina: A century and a half later, a blogger chooses the name Saudade—a word for longing that never quite resolves.
Maya: Wait. They named the blog after the feeling?
Lina: Exactly. They had left Cape Verde, and years later they still thought about it every day.
Theo: So one writer calls leaving a transplant. Another names the whole archive after the ache.
Theo: There never was a time when I was more myself, more comfortable with the skin I wore, the people I'd seen, the place I'd visited.
Lina: What gets me is that Saudade's home isn't the place they grew up. It's a place they chose and then had to leave.
Maya: And that kind of homesickness—try explaining that to someone.
Theo: The blog itself is a little mystery. The archive shows exactly one post.
Lina: It's called "Raskalnikov"—yes, Dostoevsky—but the display name is Saudade. Two literary personas are sharing one page.
Maya: And the Cape Verdean Creole isn't translated for outsiders?
Theo: No. That part of the page stays with the people who already understand it.
Maya: Maybe they weren't writing for us.
Theo: Maybe they were writing for the friends they name at the end of the post—people still in Cape Verde who'd understand every word.
Lina: Okay, now here's where Theo found something that floored me.
Maya: In another OCR scan?
Lina: Another scan, page numbers and all. And this one is a letter from Beethoven.
Maya: Wait. Beethoven?
Theo: It's addressed to Stephan von Breuning. Beethoven is writing about how his deafness keeps him from traveling—he can't go see the scenery of his fatherland, he can't marry.
Lina: And then there's this line—
Lina: Oh ! I could span the world were I only free from this ! I feel that my youth is only now commencing.
Maya: He's homesick for a life he can't get to. Not a specific house—a whole future his deafness has walled off.
Theo: And the digital version of the letter just cuts off mid-sentence. His closing words, his signature—gone. The scan or the extraction stopped before the end.
Lina: So even this archived copy of a published copy of a private letter is incomplete.
Lina: The silence belongs to the file, not necessarily to him.
Lina: Then there's Brooke Davidoff. And her story brings all of this into the present tense. She wrote a post called "Homesick" after her father died.
Maya: She's living far from southern California, where her mother and her father's house are.
Theo: The family owns the house in Wildomar together, but nobody can afford the mortgage, and nobody lives nearby.
Lina: I want to go home. The California heat and my mommy are calling. I'm not homesick, I'm heart sick.
Theo: Her post cuts off mid-sentence too—she starts describing a dream at a party and the text just stops.
Lina: We don't know if that's how she left it or if the crawl missed the rest.
Lina: Twice now, the archive has closed the door before the ending.
Maya: Four voices across two centuries. And every one of them is reaching toward a home that's already changed—or that they've changed too much to simply walk back into.
Lina: But distance does something stranger, too—it enlarges the ordinary. That's where we're headed next.
Maya: So we've been talking about what it means to leave. But distance does this strange thing — it doesn't just separate you from a place.
Theo: It takes every ordinary thing you left behind and makes it radiant.
Lina: And what he's longing for isn't grand at all. It's voices. Songs. Faces.
Maya: I sigh for rest and the sound of home
voices, the music of home songs, the light of loved eyes and
faces
Theo: He pictures himself on a little island in the boundless ocean, surrounded by travelers gambling over champagne on a Sunday.
Maya: The Sunday champagne really bothered him.
Lina: He is also harsh about foreign faces and tongues in ways that are very much of his era. That's his period-bound lens, not ours.
Maya: But that impulse — cataloguing exactly what you miss — it doesn't go away. A blogger named Emily does the same thing in 2012, from Kenya.
Theo: She's on a site called One Trailing Spouse, and she writes this list of five things she misses about the U.S. after five months abroad.
Lina: And the list is so specific it's almost funny.
Maya: How specific are we talking?
Theo: Purple corduroy pants. Her muffin tin. Netflix.
Maya: The muffin tin is the one that gets me.
Lina: And driving — just the freedom to get in a car by herself after dark. She's candid that this is a privileged perspective, she says so.
Maya: But missing the feeling of casual safety? That's real no matter how you frame it.
Maya: A commenter named Marina chimes in from England and says she hasn't worn completely dry clothes in nearly two years. She misses the sun. And avocados.
Theo: Honestly? Avocados can do that.
Lina: Then there's Kathleen, on a WordPress blog called My 8×10 Life. She grew up in the rural Midwest, moved reluctantly to Brooklyn.
Maya: And she writes about driving back through those Midwestern landscapes and feeling like she could finally stretch and breathe again — after months of swallowing the grit of New York.
Maya: But she says something that really gets me. She talks about the details of home growing fuzzy, and it bothers her.
Theo: Like the feelings of belonging are still sharp, but the specifics — they're slipping away.
Lina: But, I don’t think I’ll ever allow myself to like it, and will never love it no matter how well I adapt to the urban life. I guess it makes me feel disloyal to my roots.
Theo: Disloyal. That word. Homesickness isn't just missing a place — it becomes a kind of moral obligation to keep missing it.
Maya: We found another exile — a memoir fragment from the Internet Archive's OCR pipeline. Someone marking a thirty-seventh birthday in May 1919, living in seclusion on an island.
Theo: The narrator doesn't fully identify themselves in this fragment, but letters and flowers arrive from Germany — so many the small rooms of a parsonage can't hold them all.
Lina: What struck me is how the narrator measures belonging — not by being present, but by being remembered.
Maya: Those letters prove people still feel connected across distance and, as the writer puts it, across a wildly raging campaign of slander.
Theo: And we should be honest — we don't know from this fragment alone who the narrator is or what the slander was about. The text starts mid-sentence.
Lina: That's the nature of digitized scraps.
Lina: A gap is not permission to invent.
Maya: Which brings us to a passage that kind of names the whole feeling we've been circling.
Theo: From what appears to be volume twenty-one of the collected works of someone abbreviated 'Stev' in the filename — an essay about roads.
Lina: And the writer introduces this German word: Sehnsucht.
Lina: The passion for what is ever beyond. That ache for the horizon.
Theo: And the essay quotes Goethe's Werther to make a devastating point.
Lina: When you finally reach the distance you wanted—when 'there' becomes 'here'—everything is afterwards as it was before.
Maya: So arrival can make the dream smaller?
Theo: Exactly. You arrive, and the magic collapses.
Maya: Wheeler sighing for home voices. Kathleen gripping the steering wheel through flat fields.
Lina: Emily dreaming of purple pants. The unnamed exile counting birthday flowers.
Theo: They're all living inside that word: Sehnsucht.
Maya: But Sehnsucht changes when the distant place becomes a destination. What happens when you actually go back?
Theo: So we found a story in the crawl that lands right on this.
Lina: First-person essay by Christal Presley—originally published on CNN, then republished on a New Hampshire TV station's website, which is where the crawler actually caught it.
Maya: She's driving from Atlanta back to Honaker, Virginia. Deep Appalachia.
Lina: And she hasn't really been back in almost twenty years. Left at eighteen.
Maya: And she draws this parallel that just—she says it plainly: that was the same age her father was when he was drafted and sent to Vietnam.
Maya: I'm going home to tell my truth. I was 18 when I fled there -- the same age my father was when he was drafted and sent to Vietnam. We both ended up scarred by his war.
Theo: Both scarred by his war. That line just sits there.
Lina: Her father came home with PTSD, and the family kept it secret for years.
Maya: She describes the secret growing inside her like a cancer—those are her words.
Maya: And that's what shaped how she saw home. She writes that she'd grown to hate the mountains—the whole town.
Theo: Because she associated all of it with the secrets she was never able to tell.
Theo: Now here's where the archive does something frustrating and weirdly poetic. The captured text cuts off mid-sentence.
Lina: She's arrived at her parents' house, there's a clash with her father over a song he wrote, and—it just stops. Mid-word. We literally don't get the resolution.
Maya: So the crawl preserved the wound but not the healing. If there even was one in that moment.
Theo: And while Christal's return is about confronting trauma—we found another piece from barely thirty miles away, same region of Virginia, that's about a much quieter kind of loss.
Lina: A woman named Melva posted a poem on a personal website called Heavens Gates, describing her grandparents' homeplace in Smith Hollow near Abingdon.
Maya: The house is physically falling apart. Broken windows, rotting walls, vines climbing through the cracks.
Theo: But Melva layers in all these memories—a little girl hunting for hen's nests, riding a bike down the hill, her grandmother calling her in for supper.
Lina: With love and laughter inside those rotting walls
Theo: And the page itself is kind of a rotting house.
Maya: A MIDI file?
Theo: Set to auto-play—a song called "Old Home Place."
Lina: There's also a boilerplate lyrics disclaimer that doesn't apply to her original poem.
Maya: The poem is dated 2009, but the memorial-site design feels older. The crawler found it in 2013.
Theo: The old web had confidence.
Lina: And this pattern—going back and being stunned by the change—it's not new at all.
Maya: We found a speech from a scanned book on Archive.org, someone addressing the town of Holland, Massachusetts. His family farmed there four generations.
Theo: He left as a teenager, fought in the Civil War with the First Michigan Sharpshooters, and was—in his words—dreadfully homesick.
Maya: Then there's another scanned speech—someone returning to America after twenty years abroad.
Theo: He compares himself to Rip Van Winkle, almost appalled at the wonderful changes that meet his eyes.
Lina: He's been invited to dinners everywhere, but he only says yes to his native town of Danvers, Massachusetts.
Lina: Homecoming as time travel.
Maya: So we've talked about leaving and coming back. But here's what nobody warns you about.
Lina: Sometimes the place is still on the map, still has a zip code, and it is just… not yours anymore.
Theo: And we've got two writers in these archives doing almost the exact same thing—both walking through their hometowns, taking inventory. One's in Mt. Union, Iowa, small-town Henry County.
Lina: The other's on a courthouse square in his little Texas town. Both published around May 2013, both crawled that December.
Maya: One from the Ottumwa Courier, one from a Houston Chronicle blog.
Lina: The Iowa writer brings their daughter and baby grandson Max along. Three generations standing in a cemetery, leaving flowers at family graves. And there's this line—
Lina: Tears fell in the cemetery where we showed Max the resting places of his great-grandparents.
Lina: It gave me pause when I finally realized that I love the memory of that part of Henry County. That even though the town is still there, many of the places I knew so well are gone. And most of the people I knew who lived there are gone, too.
Theo: We should say—that column is truncated. It ends mid-sentence: 'I walked past stones,' and then nothing.
Lina: The crawler grabbed a printer-friendly page variant, you can see '/print' in the URL, and whether the full text ever made it into the archive… we just don't know.
Maya: The Texas writer has the same mid-sentence cutoff! He's walking the courthouse square, remembering every storefront, and then—gone.
Theo: And his text opens with the string 'Print67' smashed right into the first paragraph—a share-counter widget the crawler swallowed as regular text. Classic WET extraction artifact.
Maya: Print sixty-seven?
Theo: The machine thought the counter was prose.
Maya: But the memories themselves—so specific. He worked as a soda skeet for seventeen and a half cents an hour.
Lina: A soda skeet?
Lina: A bowl of chili for a dime—and then you just kept adding crackers and ketchup until you felt full. That's not nostalgia as mood.
Maya: That's nostalgia as exact price.
Theo: A dime, plus structural crackers.
Theo: He remembers carrying groceries from the Piggly Wiggly two or three blocks to somebody's house, putting the milk in their ice box.
Lina: A whole economy of proximity that's just… vanished.
Maya: And an actual ice box.
Maya: Now, both of those writers are wistful. But the Andover letter? That's a different temperature entirely.
Theo: This is a letter to the editor of the Andover Townsman, published November 2012, crawled over a year later.
Lina: A man comes back to Andover, Massachusetts after decades away and he is angry.
Maya: The town used to be known as 'Mill, Hill and Till'—and now he calls it a smaller version of New York City.
Lina: He goes through landmarks one by one—the Shawsheen River, historic dams, the old high school—and each one is either demolished, degraded, or renamed.
Maya: He sees the river and compares it to a Love Canal wasteland.
Maya: There's something uncomfortable in it too, though. Part of his argument is that newcomers don't understand the town's history, that they've diluted its values.
Theo: And that raises a real question—who gets to define a place's identity? The person who left, or the people who live there now?
Theo: The person who stayed might answer very differently.
Lina: That's the tension. The Iowa and Texas writers grieve what's gone but hold it lightly—they know the loss is partly theirs, inside them.
Maya: The Andover letter says no, the town itself is wrong now. And I think that's a really human fork in the road when your hometown changes.
Theo: Meanwhile there's a very different kind of homecoming buried in a personal blog post from Christmas Eve, 2009—captured nearly four years later.
Lina: Someone's home visiting family, loves them genuinely, but feels this ache because London has become their real center of gravity. They can't quite name the feeling.
Lina: But the fragment is enough. It's someone realizing that home has split in two—the place where your family is, and the place where you became yourself.
Maya: And those might never be the same place again.
Maya: And then there's a songwriter named Xanthe Littlemore who puts that exact feeling to music—or at least a lyrics site tried to.
Theo: The crawler grabbed preview snippets from a page whose URL slug says 'hurry up with the robots,' which doesn't match any song title on the page.
Theo: Total metadata mismatch. And the lyrics themselves are gated—only preview fragments got through. There's even a Unicode replacement character where the encoding broke.
Lina: We are literally reading through frosted glass.
Maya: Frosted glass is exactly it.
Lina: But look what survived. Under the title 'Don't Say Goodbye'—
Lina: There is a town where I used to live as a child
They tore down everything that was growing wild
And I don't like going back home, I hate to see what they've done
'Cause when I do, well, it makes me cry
Theo: We can't even hear the melody. The full lyrics were behind a login wall.
Lina: A few lines from a song by an artist most people haven't heard of, on a page that doesn't match its own URL.
Maya: That's the archive—generous and stingy in the same breath.
Lina: What strikes me across all of these is that no one finds what they went back for.
Maya: Not the cemetery visitor, not the courthouse walker, not the angry letter writer, not the blogger at Christmas. The place can't hold what they need it to hold.
Theo: So what do you do with the love that has nowhere to land?
Maya: Sometimes the place can't hold the love, so a smell, a logo, or an old object does. That's where these stories take us next.
Lina: And sometimes the longing isn't even for something you actually had.
Maya: Okay, this one genuinely surprised me. There's a blogger who ran a site called Branded in the 80s — basically a personal archive of childhood consumer culture.
Theo: And he's writing about how old packaging, old toys, can hit you like a physical force.
Theo: He's not being poetic about it, either. He means it literally.
Maya: There have been moments where I stumble across something that I completely forgot about and literally doubled over as if I were punched in the gut.
Lina: His example is painfully specific: an Otter Pop, a hot green electrical transformer box, surf shorts, and a friend talking skateboarding.
Theo: He can still feel that box burning through the fabric. That's not a concept. That's a full-body memory.
Maya: But then he finds a People magazine ad for Lacoste polo shirts — the little alligator patch — and he gets that same gut-punch of nostalgia.
Theo: And then he realizes: he never owned one.
Lina: Wait—nostalgia for a shirt he never owned?
Theo: He calls it false nostalgia — longing for something you never actually had.
Lina: He grew up in Florida surrounded by gator imagery, so the Lacoste logo felt like home even though the brand was never in his closet.
Maya: It played into this sense that I had at the time that Florida was the center of the country, the center of cool
Theo: Now — web-artifact note — we're actually reading this from two different tag-archive pages on his blog.
Lina: One filed under 'Lacoste Gator,' one under 'False Nostalgia.' Same post, two doorways.
Maya: And both versions cut off mid-sentence with a bare less-than character — the crawler hit an image tag it couldn't extract.
Theo: He was probably showing us the little alligator logo, but that image is just… gone.
Maya: The missing image is the thing doing all the work.
Lina: That same ache turns up across centuries.
Maya: Right beside this blog post in the crawl is a letter from the eighteen hundreds.
Theo: Its writer is explaining to a reverend named Cochrane why he cannot attend the centennial of a town called Antrim.
Maya: And for this man, Antrim isn't just a town. It's the only place on earth he could call home. For thirty-eight years.
Theo: For thirty-eight years it has been the only spot on earth that I could call by that peerless name, — home!
Lina: He buried his father, his mother, three sisters, and a brother in that town's cemeteries. His only son was born there. He entered the ministry there.
Maya: The homestead at Clinton holds — as he puts it — all those memories, painful and joyous, that give the word home its indescribable fascination.
Theo: And we only have this letter because it was printed in a commemorative book, scanned and OCR'd into a plain-text stream on the Internet Archive.
Lina: There's a stray page header jammed into the middle of it — 'Response of Col. Silas Dinsmore' — which isn't him at all.
Maya: Just the scanner turning a page.
Lina: A page header just walked into somebody else's letter.
Maya: A Hancock County history gives us another voice from a similar commemorative book.
Theo: Reverend William Nichols stands at an old settlers' meeting and says something that could be an instruction manual for this podcast.
Theo: At old settlers' meetings it is fitting and proper to call up the past and rehearse memories and events past and gone.
Lina: Nichols was born before Indiana was even a state.
Theo: He remembers hiding in a hollow stump at age four because a party of Indigenous people came to his father's house to trade.
Maya: We need to mark the frame: this is a settler's account of that encounter.
Lina: His childhood fear was real to him, but the story does not include the perspective of the people who were already there.
Maya: And that missing perspective matters as much as the remembered fear.
Theo: And his schoolhouse — a log hut with windows made by cutting out a log and pasting oiled paper over the hole.
Lina: That's the landscape these people are building memory from.
Maya: Which brings us to someone who grew up in a landscape most people wouldn't think to feel nostalgic about at all.
Theo: A professor named Michael Rustad, writing about the Red River Valley in northwestern Minnesota — flat black-loam prairie, endless horizon.
Lina: I grew up longing to leave the flat land.
Lina: And what changed him was a sixth-grade teacher — Dale Finney Miller — who taught Scandinavian mythology and local history, the Alexandria runestone, stories about the land under his feet.
Maya: That teacher made the place legible to him. Made it worth loving.
Maya: This essay was written in 2001, posted on a RootsWeb genealogy page — hand-coded HTML, no content-management system — and crawled twelve years later in December 2013.
Theo: We have no idea if anyone touched it in between.
Theo: The extraction cuts off mid-sentence too. He was about to say something about learning from his teachers, and then — nothing. The crawler just stopped.
Lina: Again?
Theo: Every one of these people — the blogger, the minister, Nichols, Rustad — the archive caught them.
Lina: But it can't give us back the alligator logo, or the minister's full name, or the end of Rustad's sentence.
Maya: It preserves the ache without restoring the thing that was ached for.
Maya: So we've been sitting with all these places people leave behind, and the things they build to hold onto them.
Theo: I want to end with a guy who did something I find kind of beautiful. He named his whole company after a park.
Theo: Ed Romanoff. He founded a company called PineRock.
Lina: And his about-us page—crawled December 2013—has this origin story: when he was a kid in Connecticut, there was a park called PineRock Park. Baseball, live music, giant swings.
Maya: And he just… kept carrying it.
Lina: He named the future after the feeling.
Maya: I didn't know what I wanted to be when I grew up, but I did know that I wanted to create something that moved me in that same way. And I decided that when I did, I would call it PineRock.
Lina: Okay, yes, it's a corporate page—it's branding. But the impulse underneath it is real.
Maya: You take a childhood feeling and pour it into a name so it outlives the place itself.
Maya: And that's what we keep finding. The archive holds evidence of longing, not the thing longed for. And sometimes the longing shows up in the weirdest containers.
Theo: Theo, tell them about the Halloween candle guy.
Theo: Okay. So there's a blogger on Branded in the 80s—writes about retro toys, ThunderCats, G.I. Joe, the whole universe. And he's self-aware about it. He actually says—
Theo: “This junk doesn’t hold a candle to the stuff from back in my day…” I’m not that guy, or at least I don’t want to be.
Lina: He calls himself an amateur semiotician.
Maya: On a blog about Smurfs.
Theo: Which is a wonderful sentence.
Maya: But then he says his year has been rough. And Halloween is the one season where he can let go and just feel something good.
Theo: He ends up at a Yankee Candle browsing the Boney Bunch collection with his spouse, and the blog entry literally cuts off mid-sentence during that visit.
Theo: And there goes the sentence again.
Maya: Fragments keep being the theme. There's a poem on PoetrySoup by Andrew Nashat called "Do you remember."
Lina: We only have a name on a community poetry site; we don't know more about the writer.
Theo: The whole poem is built on that phrase, repeated like a heartbeat.
Lina: I remember the days when all we wanted to do was be together, I remember the days when all we wanted to do was be there for each other, I remember the days when all we did was reminisce our childhood memories, I remember those days my dear.
Theo: That repetition sounds like someone trying to keep a door open.
Maya: And then it shifts. He asks: why is there a block of ice forming between us? Home isn't a place in this poem. It's a person.
Theo: And that person is slipping away.
Theo: Which brings us—weirdly—all the way back to Beethoven.
Lina: The crawl picked up an OCR scan of a printed edition of his letters, served as a text file on archive.org.
Maya: And in this fragment—and I mean fragment, it opens and closes mid-sentence—he's writing about leaving his fatherland and about a friend.
Lina: since I left my fatherland, you are one of those to whom my heart specially clings.
Maya: He's talking about Stephan von Breuning, a childhood friend who has come back into his life.
Lina: Then he says he has to withdraw from everyone because of his hearing loss.
Theo: The people he most wants to reach are the very people he is being pulled away from.
Lina: Think about the layers between us and that voice. A hand writes a letter. An editor prints it.
Maya: A scanner reads it. A crawler captures it.
Theo: Then we find it two hundred years later in a file called beethovensletter001beet underscore djvu dot txt.
Maya: That filename is practically sediment.
Lina: And that's what an archive actually does, isn't it. A company named for a park that may be gone. A Halloween blog that stops mid-sentence.
Maya: A poem to someone drifting away. A letter from a man going deaf, reaching for a friend. The archive keeps the reaching.
Theo: It can't give back the thing that was reached for.
Theo: We can't restore the home, the person, the page—or even the full context that produced any of these. We just know someone was here.
Lina: And they wanted something badly enough to write it down.
Maya: And that the web remembered it—even partially, even broken—that matters.
Lina: Thanks for listening. The homes we leave behind don't disappear. They just change shape—into names, into rituals, into poems, into letters that open and close mid-sentence.
Maya: We'll see you next time.